okay last bit now I'm actually good
looking for a bit of them okay what's
the quickest time so in order to get
that I've already got an expression for
the total time taken advil tea and what
I can vary the thing I have control over
is where I land what X is right so
therefore what driven in my mother
detail from all DX that's what I want
okay that's a little bit messy but it's
not impossible okay you've got your
you're gonna have Chamberlain coming out
here it looks to be like I'm going to go
half nine plus x squared to the minus a
half times 2x there's the driven on the
inside and that's just the numerator so
I'm dividing everything by 2 okay with
that is that okay so far so good yeah
yeah yes um because if I'm
differentiating this of differentiate
top chooses one but then i'm dividing
the whole p by 2 2 b-room this is a half
that's not one right write it as half x
and then yeah yeah so it's if I'm
differentiating this whole thing I can't
just take the two away just like the
derivative of this is different it's
just the constant just a constant
coefficient so I've taken care of this
guy with some simplifying to be done and
then my other one is here right now that
Ted over 5 is just to differentiate away
with my left with this will become minus
1 negative 1 over 5 okay let's just tie
this thing up it means it'll cancel this
should be on the denominator right so it
looks like i'm getting x on to route 9
plus x squared take away fit happy with
that Zach what my derivative looks like
okay now what was the point of
differentiated good I want to find the
minimum which is we're turning points
will be on it
point so i will say possible Tony points
at where this derivative is zero that's
what I'm a song for okay so you go ahead
and solve now i'm going to save you a
bit of time when you put these together
right so you've got X on 29 plus x
squared equals hug fifth UK with that
right you're going to square stuff out
and where do we get to just to save a
good time um you're going to get to this
point god I believe this is where you
end up as you start to tidy UK with that
right but of course we have two
solutions for this one of which is
within the domain and one of which is
not right so at this point I said mg
equals the square root of 12 on seven I
only take the positive case and I state
why because of my domain okay I haven't
answered the question yet right what I'm
looking for is where do I get the
minimum and have endpoints you right
yeah well you know in the deputy home so
yeah all right now therefore what am I
going to do with this right I'm going to
be a bit silly and I'm not going to
worry about testing the nature of the
stationary point I don't need to can you
see why a couple of reasons number one
I'm gross I don't differentiate this is
damn ok secondly secondly because I have
to test the end points anyway right the
end point i'm not at 10 right so when i
do my table is now is over here
okay when I do my table of values I'm
testing for values of X and I'm trying
to determine all right what is the
actual time I end up with what's the
actual time now if I go 0 square root of
12 on 7 and 10 remember i found this is
the only stationary point in the domain
it can't do any other wiggling around
there's no possibility of any other
minima existing these are real right
you've got this endpoint this endpoint
and this stationary point and those are
your only choices right so if it ends up
being a maximum doesn't matter I just
ignore it and take an endpoint right I
don't need to worry about that does that
make sense I do need some actual numbers
here okay now i have some natural
numbers you're going to have to pop
these back into your function for tea
which includes these two here and i
believe you get this three-point dot dot
dot and 5.22 okay I think I you check if
you get your same numbers with that you
do need to get numbers you actually have
to demonstrate that the endpoints are
not going to be part of your actual
minimum okay do you see by the way had I
at this point spend like five minutes in
here determining the nature of the
stationary point right and finding all
great it's a minimum which which it is
right at that point I still have to test
the endpoints anyway I haven't saved
myself any effort right so that is why I
never go to the second derivative I
don't do a table values for the first
review I don't need to my actual values
here in test me endpoint up perfectly
sufficient so there you go I have a
minimum right there it is now just to
save you a bit of time because this will
frequently happen and you're the time
here right so if you have all your
decimal places there i have three point
three seven four seven seven two seven
zero eight okay once you do that
generally speaking i mean a question
didn't ask your tooth but it's a time so
i'll expect you put it in hours 10
minutes all you need to do is press her
degrees minutes seconds button and i
would convert it to this
three Andrew say that advance and I
think it says that something like that
ok so this I read as three degrees
twenty-two minutes and 29 seconds is
exactly the same as three hours 22
minutes and 29 seconds right so 29
seconds rounds down so there's my answer
three hours and 22 minutes okay